wow wow wow thank you thank you hold on
how do I lower this oh wow hi hi
you are the most beautiful looking group
of people I've ever seen oh my gosh wow
okay let's do two one three
first of all can you believe I'm holding
one of this
this is so surreal wow
so this is this is the famous room where
all the winners come wow hi good evening
uh yes yeah please share yeah
hi uh HIPAA Berry with Entertainment
Tonight now when you start in Goonies
and Indiana Jones you were credited as
Jonathan Ki Quan what does it mean to
win an Oscar with your real name in it
you know when I started as a kid I I was
you know it was my birth name
and then I remember uh when it got
really tough my manager told me that
maybe you know it would be easier if you
would have an American sounding name uh
and I was so desperate for a job that I
would do anything and it's insane uh
that I at one point that I would you
know
try a different name not the name that
was given to me but it can only show you
how desperate
I I was to try to try to try to make
things different uh so when I decided to
get back into acting which was three
years ago uh the very first thing that I
wanted to do was to go back to my most
given name uh and to to to uh tonight to
see
to see how Rihanna opened that envelope
and say kiwi Kwan that was a really
really special moment for me and then
immediately I was so emotional but the
first image
that I had
in my mind was my mom
was my mom who is the reason why I am in
America
who's the reason why I have a better
life I have all these opportunities she
like I said in my accepting speech you
know uh she sacrificed so much uh she
had a great life where we came from and
uh and and she you know she she gave all
that up so that all her children there's
nine of us there's nine of us and every
single one of them are so grateful to my
parents yeah so and and that that
I hope you're proud of me so next up we
have 101
[Applause]
hi key hi my name is Ryan omodo on
behalf of the academy digital team
congratulations on your win thank you
you mentioned in an interview when you
first got the roles Layman you were kind
of hesitant to tell your family about
getting the role and it wasn't until the
day before the trailer release that you
called your family individually and told
them that you're an actor now so how
does it feel to call yourself an Oscar
winner tonight and be here
you know
tonight my my my my my family
a portion of them I have a big family
flew in from Houston to to be with me
tonight uh so that was really special
and uh
during one of the commercial breaks I I
ran up to Stephen Spielberg
ah and he gave me a big hug
he put his arms around me and he says
key
you are now an Oscar winning actor
and hearing him say that
meant the world to me and uh and I I
still could not believe it uh uh yeah I
mean
wow wow
hi
uh two three one
yes hi
hi congratulations Amanda champagne with
closer weekly if your younger self could
be here now at the age of data and your
younger goonie brothers were here what
would they say to you right now well my
younger self uh uh would not know all
the struggles that I went through to be
here uh because he was just having the
time of his life being a kid being on a
set
uh with with you know uh on a pirate
ship going down a water slide uh and you
know right before I this this night
started uh koi Feldman one of my Goonies
brother called uh I was talking to
Carrie green and of course tonight
Jeff Cohen
uh who is my entertainment lawyer is
here tonight with me he was it was he
was in the audience uh and that's why I
wanted to thank him because uh uh I I
love all of them so much and every
single one of them was so happy Sean
reached out Josh Martha uh and uh you
know we are always bonded uh uh you know
we're family forever Goonies Never Say
Die
thank you
okay and final question two three two
hello congratulations I think
um you know a lot of people I'm Mary
madaya from CBC Radio Canada a lot of
people think of you as a very positive
person relate to you in numerous ways my
question to you tonight is you know this
is a very important moment in your
career how do you just stay humble and
true to yourself through through your
whole career through your life it it's
how I was brought up is how I was taught
and also if that's why I always say
never forget where you came from because
uh if you forget that
all humility goes out the window uh I
remember how how how difficult it was
for me so that's why every time I walk
on a movie set I'm so grateful uh this
tonight was it certainly wasn't you know
I I didn't I didn't think this was
possible uh but I yeah I don't ever want
to forget that and I always want to uh
uh I I I think I think it's important to
to to to to appreciate uh where you are
uh and yeah I'm just
I'm just so grateful uh I I've said this
maybe some of you have heard it uh you
know
I I didn't think any of this would be
possible
uh and uh
yeah I'm
God it has been so crazy all of a sudden
my mind is thrifting
back to uh to the days when I lost my
health insurance
uh during the pandemic when I couldn't
get a job
um and you know I somebody asked me this
earlier do I have anything planned what
am I doing next I don't know what I'm
doing next uh and but all I know is the
first thing tomorrow I'm gonna call my
agent
because I remember I remember when I was
struggling I would always I would call
my agent I try not to bother them too
much but I would call them you know once
every three months one every six months
and I would say Hey you know uh is there
anything out there for me uh and the
answer would always be the same oh I'm
so sorry there's nothing out there but
I'll continue to look so hopefully when
I call my agent tomorrow he will give me
a different answer
yeah thank you so much thank you so much
thank you so much I love you all I love
you all love you love you love you love
you